good morning Millennials
good morning Millennials this morning
millennial
good morning Millennials welcome to the
morning show streaming exclusively on
YouTube today because God listens to the
morning toast as just Mark Zuckerberg
and Jackie and I have been going back
and forth between the idea of just
getting rid of the Facebook stream
because it's just not premium and we're
done with Facebook and we can't make any
money there and then all of a sudden
today Facebook malfunctions and it's
like this is what God wanted so we have
to respect it right and so we're excited
to see all of you on YouTube we're
watching live on YouTube you know what
let's keep everyone like an extra 30
seconds like they'd go to Facebook where
does this dream and then they see the
post so like let's just okay we'll wait
teacher style quiet for the podcast
though Oh Cho Cho Cho well um how was
your night my night was horrible
oh you were sick uh in between the time
I left your apartment and got to my
apartment I got so sick he poisoned no I
was like worse might know if anything it
was like it was Thea withdrawal I had
the room had the worst migraine ever
eyes oh that's the worst
I literally laid in bed like with an ice
pack on my head like until I fell asleep
like wanting to die I thought like I
could die right now yeah it was horrible
a migraines it just kept moving until it
was just in my eye yeah
there's no cure for migraines which is
why it's like one of the worst things to
suffer from oh my god I I was like
crying I was in so much pain you should
have joined the there's a chronic
migraine toasters group but I didn't I
don't want to deal with your pain on top
of my pain what do I ask them for
remedies and like for the most part I
had tried most of the stuff that
everyone posted weird acupuncture and
like nothing works like let's say I get
a migraine probably once a week and
maybe five out of those months a year
weeks a year sorry just excedrin work
like that's oh yeah I just earned this
like a gamble I 10% of the bad bill no
[ __ ] advil never works
it's Evers unless it's like the most
conventional pain like I don't know like
right like back pain right like the most
easy pain and like the real most the
time when I have pain it like I can't
diagnose what it is so I just like take
adults like see if it'll work like it
never does unless it's like my like I
got a cut or something like it's just it
was just simple no but it's not
and while working it's like the cut just
stopped hurting advil does absolutely
nothing last night it didn't even touch
my migraine it was so horrible and
painful and like I'm I was just so
grateful to wake up this morning and be
okay
so what sometimes like pretty much the
only thing that gets sort of a migraine
is to go to sleep and I don't believe in
there's anything worse on this planet
then waking up with the migraine like it
was so strong and getting glass that is
like pure evil it's like you think and
falling asleep in with a migraine is so
hard because you're so focused on just
being asleep cuz you're in pain
yeah I'd like to sleep is hard enough
then on top of that with a migraine like
I've never been one of those people who
like has true both falling asleep
actually I actually used to like when I
was in high school like there was so
many pits in high school like things
that kept me up at night and then like
the second me and then started sleeping
in the same bed like I've never had him
at a sleepless night no I feel like in
high school I used to fall asleep
quicker cuz like your days were just so
jam-packed yes I cry time you got to bed
like you were just tired but now I have
a lot on my mind like real people
problems and like it's sometimes I call
asleep easily and sometimes it takes me
a while well do you know there's one
there's like one prescription pill for
migraines that's like crack like where
do I got it
so been used to have it cuz been been
like gave me migraines like I never
really got migraines I got like
headaches like frequently been came up
with his chronic migraines when we
started dating and like passed them on
to me and like now it's my problem and
there's this pill I forget what it is
it's like so expensive and been hata and
one day I had like the worst migraine
and I took it and I like took a bath
took it and went to bed and I had the
worst anxiety attack like and I don't
get anxiety like I'm not I don't really
have issues like that and I was in my
bed my heart was pounding so fast I
could hear it I was screaming at the top
of my lungs I'm like I just literally
remember getting to Mom's bed and like
literally freaking out and I could never
take a pill again so I don't know if it
works I guess I'm okay my anxiety not my
sister it definitely works but that
would happen to you
of course where do I get the pill any
toaster doctors if you guys want to make
yourself useful and write some
prescriptions you know where to find me
yeah by the way email in Baia
I'm always like leaning on the toasters
for stuff like I don't feel like I put
stuff out there and the toaster somehow
likes one toaster works in marketing
like one dose is a police officer now we
have PDA
yeah it was the bar we sued okay yeah
but I've been putting out like four
years about prescriptions but like that
borders on like illegal and that's like
the one thing I haven't been able to get
from the toasters you know what I mean
or we can write it ourselves Betty
Hooper style I mean close enough is I
have a toaster who works in marketing
for tums and excedrin and sends me
yearly supplies and that's close because
Tom's an excedrin can be lifesavers but
it's not the same I need a prescription
pad and a doctor who doesn't know how to
write notes I using a prescription pad
like I could figure out the rest
actually I couldn't I don't even know
what to prescribe myself but migraine
medication will help because if I ever
feel the way that I did last night
like shoot me I I don't know what to do
I was with a what cold washcloth on my
head Zach was bringing me bags of ice
and like there was nothing nothing I
don't know what Ben does actually he
does two things and if you ever migraine
you have to go over to your house and
make bed and rub your face okay he just
he rubbed his thumbs are so big and hard
and he literally just like rubs
underneath and around your eyes and like
your face and it doesn't help but like
momentarily you forget about the
migraine then he does is also a weird
acupressure thing where like he shoves
his thumbs up okay I mean to do that
okay it does provide temporary relief
but the migraine always comes back
nothing could help me last night like
when you're when you have a migraine
like you're open to any stupid
suggestion I one time sat up on my sink
countertop put my feet in very hot water
and put frozen peas on my neck which is
like the contrast of the hot and the
cold this what's up oh my god I felt so
stupid and I couldn't really bend over
like that well I had an iced snack on my
scalp and he had on my belly and I was
like this is stupid
yeah and then I was sweating but
whatever anyways up until the migraine
it was an amazing night we watched
Riverdale brought his apartment nephew's
knee test was a perfect angel boy
perfect angel boy like every time he
comes over I think he knows he's like
auditioning for Zac's approval because
Jackie really wants a dog on exacts like
on the fence about it so every time he
sees Theo like Theo is like what could
be for him and I told Theo C's cousin's
knee chest right I told Theo I said I'm
you better behave because a lot is on
the line for your for your aunt so you
better hop to it and if you want cousin
citas from the same litter right Mike
and the thing is like with vo if you see
him after eight or nine o'clock he is
just like even if he had like a relaxing
day
even if he had the craziest day like he
is dead eight o'clock the clock strikes
eight and he's dead like he is asleep
anywhere on a carpet on the floor and
your arms on the couch so he's really
like so pure and like you could just
like chill with him on your lap and he's
like the best version of himself he's
not like running around like trying to
play which is cute - and luckily
Riverdale starts at 8:00 so sack and I
because we don't get the CW I thought
they came over to like hang out and I
was like Jackie said i'ma come over
about trimmed oh my god and then she
likes accent come to him like it's a
family affair and like my new house I'm
like entertaining and Jackie's like when
they get there they're like we don't
have to CW and I'm like well that's why
we had to make arrangements but it was a
fun plan it was and we got some clothes
here me and Maeby's by next week my
[ __ ] couch will be there some of you
and Zach when I'm so like cuddle up on
the tiny little couch right but also
after watching last night's episode of
Riverdale like I don't know if I can
watch me tweak anymore the only reason
why I would do it is for the toaster so
you can talk about it by the way we will
recap it at the end of the episode but
it's like the way I watched the first
season of where real like all together
was the most joyous experience of my
life and like watching it we tweak like
one gives me pts scenes from after day
and two like it's just hard to keep up
I'd like to know how I feel and with
dementia and everything it really is
hard to remember what happened
especially Lesley and there's so much
going on and now there's a mountain joy
Lea is has been what else what's it
called Brandon Brandon no it's just it's
like and there's so much stupidity going
on like I can't keep up and there was
there was so much stupidity last season
like it's really be like getting hard to
keep up with the stupidity and I think
that looks like a really spoiled
television for me that like I cannot
because either I'm watching a show
that's like a Hulu or Netflix where like
I just watch it all or I'm watching
something that has eight seasons already
and I binge it out like now I'm watching
Blue Bloods week to week I'm like this
sucks
I watched eight seasons in a month I
just wet shits Creek week to eat glass
there no especially cuz those episodes
are legit 18 minutes right and it's like
that's it oh and now watching Desperate
Housewives and I got to like a climax
until I finished the season two finale
and it's just like it not to sound like
an old person or anything but like they
don't make TV like they used to they do
in it was a two-part season finale last
night and just everything happened like
and by the way I went to it was such a
pit I was like telling them because like
tom has the love child with that
horrible woman who's from a boys
magazine 3930 she's a editor-in-chief
did you come
cupcakes in your purse yes that's what I
was trying to think of last night I was
like who's that woman she's on it I
don't know who she is
yes he's a love child what magic but
that's who she plays and then [ __ ]
Carlos who iced and had sex with Xiao
Mei who's an ungrateful [ __ ]
Gaby gave her a whole life and Gaby was
so good to her gay for that brace and
then she wasn't [ __ ] her husband in the
car
I was I was like so upset by it like I
don't know why I feel really connected
to those marriages like they're really
strong and they have their problems like
I feel like I don't feel betrayed on
behalf of both of the literature but
like lest we forget
that she was having sex with John Tucker
okay but here's the thing
then I'm not an advocate for adultery
but like their their marriage was
different that it was so different like
he was with Tanaka he was never home and
he was like kind of mean and borderline
abusive remember like they alluded to
have any like grabbed her like it was
weird and it was different and I'm not
saying it was okay but like it was
definitely not as worse it's like them
working on their marriage her getting up
right there having a kid like really for
him and like changing who she is and
like he's [ __ ] and like everything
was so good and I just like love them
together and I'd love Carlos and I'm so
mad like and I went to bed and I
couldn't sleep
actually I do sometimes get up at night
and I was just like really upset because
I could just imagine first of all I had
such a pit for Lynette like Tom didn't
really do anything wrong like this lady
had a kid and didn't tell him but like
what a pit like have a life with someone
and then know like there's another life
no and like now it's your problem and
right and you're into any and then you
work hard at your ad agency to hand over
30,000 dollars to the psychopath like
that just give me Pitt and then I just
like felt fur for Gaby I was really
upset like that whole wealth Bree have
to wait and then Bree Danielle and they
found out that Caleb wasn't the killer
like it was the other brother who almost
tried to kill Brittany and she checked
herself into the institution oh and
Orson who was also an institution
visiting his friend ran over Mike yes oh
my god that's a weird story line because
then he totally pivots and then him it
might become friend and it makes no
sense yeah thanks for ruining it cuz I
don't even know what happens oh well he
you know that Daenerys Bree yes I know
so then he's a member of the community
like not not remembering stuff has
really made it like so pleasurable is
like I'm watching it all over no and we
were so young we were we were too young
to be watching like a lot of what was
going on but we didn't understand that
also justice for Karl
he's the catch of the century
justice is surfer Karl and I got taken
what he loves Susan so much and he
bought her a house when she was in that
stupid RV like that was so stupid
justice boy not remember what happens
with Karl yes I remember I didn't want
to trigger my memories okay but you're
gonna be so pleased good
and obviously human Edie were great yeah
and like Edie burning down Susan's house
she should have okay first of all lest
we forget
Susan burned down her house Susan stole
her man Susan so meet her like she
deserved it it was about time Susan got
some like [ __ ] kick a kick in the ass
totally sorry I just like need to con
that it gave me a huge pit and like I
still love Carlos Solis and like what is
he up to now as an actor I don't know
but I feel like he's very versatile like
he could be businessman he was like he
was business an whose prisoner right he
was awesome masseuse at one point he's
blind a blind masseuse what yeah he goes
why stop stop I really just I only
remember him going behind cuz you know
Rachel Ashton or when we were in middle
school ruined it for me because every
week we used to watch and he didn't
watch on Sunday she goes can you believe
Carlos is blind I said what and I'll
never forget her for it well when he's
mind his profession becomes masseuse and
he makes a woman orgasm yeah and then
she's a test of them okay but I really
don't wanna know her anyways and we'll
recap Riverdale after the past five
engagement because it was a very
conflicting episode and they just want
to thank every toaster who dm's me at
9:39 because the movie we were supposed
to go to was at 9:40 to bring my glasses
they all reminded me God you guys so
keen after Riverdale I just like
couldn't get up and I didn't want to see
the movie because it's starting at 9:40
and that meant I would have been home by
midnight and I just like need it to be
in bed watching Desperate Housewives so
I gave Margo my ticket to go with her
friend and I will see it eventually
maybe Sunday yeah it's just like my
lifestyle currently ain't God I didn't
go because there would have been a death
in the theatre death in the theatre no
but like I my lifestyle these days it's
just like not accommodating to like
sitting in the movie theater for three
hours either because I'm home so
infrequently that like when I am home
like I have to be in my bedroom or I'm
not home so I need someone to figure out
it's like get me up someone pirate it
for me and put on my computer so I can
watch it on the plane yeah that's how I
know some of you like work in the
industry you have screeners get it to
her yeah that's enough please I need it
for my health for sure so we can talk
about on the show and so I can finally
like tell you all my thoughts I was
supposed to see it last night and I'm
seeing it again on Friday night so I was
gonna see it three times but now would
only know two times Oh people wanted to
update with Brielle oh because on the
show yesterday as you guys know I'm
coming to Atlanta tomorrow night 8 p.m.
at the buyers theater make sure buy
tickets a car with um job calm we're so
close to selling out an 1,100 person
theater like I just [ __ ] love the
toaster it's like just make your friend
come or just buy ticket and like you
don't have to come up and write you the
$25 so we deemed her last night night I
said you should come we crafted a
message I told her I would give her
tickets and she broke back after the
show she was like oh my god yes I would
love to it's supposed to be Ariana's
homecoming but maybe I'll just skip it
and I'm like alright well I'll leave a
couple tickets for you I'll call and
just like let me know and she did
respond but like she knows that the
tickets are there and like she might
show up and Heather my fans got me do
very exciting a toast of Atlanta
literally I was going to say like when I
go to cities as she'd like invite local
celebs just like for press like who else
is in Atlanta
I mean besides all the house sides like
I don't have any connections with them
mm-hmm stranger things Oh Chris and did
the nicest thing should you invite
million Bobby Brown totally what a
Christian dude is teammate Liz I she
said because I put in my Instagram story
that little you're my Stalin in Atlanta
and the show takes place in Atlanta and
I'm in Atlanta in the tiny state that
she's gonna be like my vibe this weekend
and Liz was Kristen our friend Christian
co-host sometimes she's friends with Liz
Gillies say like when two high school
they're like best friends she said she
told Liz about my show and like told her
she's gone and I didn't hear back but
like whatever Liz Gillies like her drama
job good enough for me
totally okay without further ado here
are the fast five stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast okay
today's stories are celebrity heavy it
hasn't been one of those days in a while
no and the world turned allall yes the
world turned some interesting stuff the
world was turned the world was turned in
so is Selena Gomez because she enters
mental health treatment facility asked
after hospitalizations okay according to
TMZ who was the first to report the news
Gomez suffered an apparent emotional
breakdown following two hospitalizations
within the last few weeks related to her
lupus and last year's kidney transplant
the outlet reports that Gomez received
medical treatment at cedars-sinai in LA
after her white blood cell count became
increasingly low a reduction in the
number of white blood cells is called
kopi nia and is sometimes common for
those with active lupus
earlier this year Gomez completed a two
week treatment program in NYC for
anxiety and depression she is currently
reportedly receiving treatment including
dialectical behavior therapy at the same
psychiatric facility
so enews has a statement from her camp
or an insider Selena has been really
trying too hard recently to remain
focused and not let her health affect
her she has been actively writing new
music and moved to Orange County for a
change of pace and a breath of fresh air
and to be on the Real Housewives
ultimately with all of her rising health
issues Selena started to feel super
overwhelmed okay so I feel like in in
her entire career this is maybe now her
third or fourth stint in a facility that
we know about it's like celebrities go a
lot for like two weeks at a time and
don't tell anyone and each time it's
been some issue related to her mental
health and I do think that mental health
is a real issue that a lot of people
suffer from but those people are not
Selena Gomez and like just stop playing
with us like we know what's really going
on the rinds don't mine right it's just
like it's so and you know for a
celebrity of her level to be releasing
this much information about like what
she's going through and like what exact
treatment she's getting white-blood-cell
she has right it's like we are need to
hide something so like here's a bunch of
facts that like couldn't could be true
you know like I feel like if someone of
her level like really like was getting
the help that she needed like it would
be much more like under lock and key and
if she said even if she admitted she was
gonna go to some facility she would say
like she's just seeking treatment for
anxiety depression etc etc it's like
they need to prove that like this is a
thing so like they're releasing like a
random medical record so I'm like when
she was six you know yeah and it sounded
to see like really [ __ ] up if it is
the case that like she is she's gone to
the hospital two times recently like we
don't think it's for mental health
issues um but that she's like bringing
her lupus and her kidney transplant into
this and like it reflects badly on like
her doctor that like her kriti
transplant has gone so awry um also
francia raisa like the angel who gave
her her kidney like imagine who keeps
him on your kidney and then they just
like keep doing drugs with it and like
that's what got their first one like
done in the first place but it's just
like she's also someone that's just she
needs to be given a break like by
society and her managers and everything
like she doesn't
be working she does need to be unlike
talkie-talkie with cardi B and DJ snake
you know what I feel like society
doesn't demand that of her it's
literally her team who would like me I
got Bernice her like that props her up
like makes her go to the mecca of
looking Tara Wylde
and it's like coach and Tiffany's yeah
we're doing this to her and it's like
literally her being dead weekend at
Bernie's like generates more revenue
then like literally anyone in Hollywood
it's the craziest thing and I feel like
as a consumer of pop culture like I once
seen in a like you can take it like a
couple of years off when you need it and
you don't bring that much to the table
but like I will certify so you do you I
think I speak on behalf of all the
toasters actually like take some time
for yourself because you really need it
but it's not us
I don't think the public is like
demanding that she comes out but now
even when she was like working full-time
like she didn't do anything like she had
a couple she had one album like
literally on Monte Carlo right okay like
it's like the jig is up but you weren't
even doing anything when you were
working so just like take the time off
it's her like there are plenty of girls
who can like sing on his head songs you
know sign but there are like literally
like I feel like 10 people in Hollywood
like agents managers publicist whose
entire like livelihood it depends on
Selena Gomez showing up to her fake
coach event so you know what I mean yeah
but like I could give you guys a list of
like people who I would rather buy a
coach bag from happily Chloe grace
Moretz she's not
yeah no Claudia joy Jackie out do you
know right yeah no I've heard really
good things about them
yeah I'm only positive of course Kiernan
Shipka she's on Sabrina the Teenage
Witch literally anyone put her in a
coach bag I think any Mendes can be um
cami and Lily so cute I'm surprised I'm
done going to Sweetwater River with
their coach bags I'm surprised they even
don't like a big Bongo or like they did
Billabong they literally did that did
that it was like mango it's like
Pandey's michael so you get is so
Riverdale they did it is they're good
money they're the biggest yeah the
biggest nest
oh yeah oh yeah well we wish Alina go
miss the best whatever it is that she is
going through but like I don't know wish
she would just be honest oh yeah I also
wish her honesty right because there is
something humbling about just like being
dealing with the people who literally
made you what you are and it's like stop
like we know but it's like her fans are
such fools you know that's what that's
what blows my do you ever have these
moments where like you think about the
world yes like from above let you map
like what is this all for you get a
bird's-eye view of like earth
and I have moments like that where I'm
like wow there are people who like walk
around this earth thinking that like
Selena Gomez is like a very private
person who just like wants to hang out
and play board games with her family and
then occasionally has to check in to
like sis facilities because she has eggs
and when she lives wacky it's her hair
and makeup team's fault not right like
there are people who read like Us
magazine and believe it like I live in
on different planet than those people
look I live in reality hunter except I
don't know what the [ __ ] you live Thank
You % it's so crazy like it really blows
my mind it's sad if you think about it
so many people maybe more sadder for us
though because like we know all these
things and it's we're so frustrated and
angry and we're like begging her to be
honest where it's like they live in a
simpler life just thinking she's like
suffering from anxiety and depression
and you know a lot of issues that a lot
of people suffer from and she's just
another one about and they said like she
really needs to become friends with me
again because I feel like of everyone in
Hollywood and there are so many who
suffer with substance abuse problems
like Demi does it in the most real
organic way but if I understand only one
who's had success really if I were Demi
I would never want to be fine oh very
like I was like all of this so publicly
I'm so honest about like all of my
struggles and like you do the same thing
but you pretend like you're better than
me oh I completely agree on I'm saying
for Selena like Demi would be a good
person for her to be friends with Demi
like I feel like literally she's the
only person in Hollywood he was like so
upfront about her struggles with
substance abuse and like publicly like
yes I'm gonna rehab because I relapsed
and I did this like she doesn't have her
team hiding the fact that she was
checked into the hospital for an
overdose like there someone told me I
don't want to say who it is but it was
really good source that law enforcement
is called to Selena Gomez's house like
very frequently and she refuses
treatment to the hospital because once
you go to the hospital there's an
ambulance like it's a whole media circus
like and they always find out if you're
in the hospital but like they take a
narcan and they don't call they don't
allow themselves to be taken to the
ambulance enamelling spas are fine yeah
click please
Demi Lovato is like so honest and like
is actually a good role model in a weird
way and Selena Gomez is just like out
here pretending not cool like think of
the good that you can be doing with your
platform it's funny cuz she think she's
doing good right telling coach bags
no like Demi Lovato's literally the only
honest person in Hollywood and I just
want her to be friends with Kim they are
friends I think they are too okay next
up I'm obsessed with this story what
does a Channing Tatum is dating Jessie J
moving on
Channing Tatum stating Jessie J
following his split from Jenna Dewan Us
Weekly can exclusively reveal Tatum and
Jessie have been seeing each other for a
couple months sources confirmed to us
the actor has been spotted at the
Dominos singers recent concerts in
Seattle and Salt Lake City according to
social media user the player the pair
played mini golf at a local course in
Seattle on Saturday October 6
most recently Tatum was was spotted at
Jessie's show in Salt Lake City on
October 8 o a second source tells us
that it's new casual and they're having
fun together I'm so here for this no to
supremely talented people getting
together okay what could be better I
just like don't you feel like Jessie J
is so odd like what I think of her
career cuz like here's what I know about
Jessie J random good songs like on the
radio never like the face that you know
on the cover of every magazine but like
good good music she performed in a cast
on some award show which I'll never
forget then she was on like a Chinese
America's Got Talent
vibe like a Chinese town show yeah and
by the way she was amazing and you
should watch her videos like she selects
only the most premium songs and like she
fell off the face of the earth for a
while and then like wrote a song for
pitch perfect like I don't get her
celebrity like what would you say she is
b-list no I don't know because her
talent is a list and it when she ever
performs we ever see her before I'm like
she is an unbelievable singer and
songwriter completely grand for a while
she was making like hit after hit like
Domino is an amazing thing
bang bang she let her whole like album I
seen is called masterpieces such a good
album now because I'm a big fan of her
music she comes up on my release radar
and like every song she releases is
trash oh really I don't know what
happened as someone she's not on my
release radar I haven't heard about her
like and I know her and I'm familiar
with her and I'm a consumer of all
things pop culture and I haven't heard a
piece of news about Jesse James
literally since it was a BuzzFeed
article that she's on the Chinese
challenge oh okay I'm gonna give you a
piece of news better that you're gonna
laugh at what so a while back she had a
new song called Queen
and it would came out on Spotify and she
took a screenshot of her like release
radar and Queen was like the first song
on the playlist and she was like oh my
gosh thank you spotted Nicki Minaj is
good she was like Thank You Spotify for
putting like cleanest number one on in
the playlist but your release radar is
tailored to you of course she doesn't
James a song that's gonna be let's do a
lot of her music she was like Spotify in
her own book I would say that's like
such a metaphor you know that's really
sad it was like really cute and like
pure you know I don't know I don't have
anything against her well I would just
love to know in what circle she ran into
Channing Tatum who is like a berry a
list star right but this this is a
rising tide raising both ships like he
needs a high-profile relationship like
she needs some positive buzz I'm sorry
not Jessie I called her Jessie James
what's her name Jessie Jessie J letter J
or J a jet letter J okay yeah this is
this is weird and like I don't know why
I like when you think of people like in
life I just don't think of Jessie J it's
like a person who has sex do you know I
mean like when I see her I'm just like I
never think about like sometimes when I
see celebrities I'm like oh she's cute
naked and like she was sup crazy sex
with you know okay like here's a cute
picture of her maybe you think of her
differently no I don't see like I just
think of her like as someone with no
vagina do you know what I mean I
understand what you mean like kendall
Jenner vibes for sure I don't think that
way about her but I understand why you
think that because in all of like her
cover like her artwork for her albums
like and she comes off as very like
intense
Villante right short hair like it's a
very intense so that's exactly what it
is intense its intense this picture of
her is like a lot sweeter she looks like
a regular girl in the club you know and
honestly like this could be a good pair
but you know the blinds say that
Channing Tatum is just like an
outrageous cheater and that's what
happened with Jenna Dewan so I don't
have like a I don't see a bright future
for these these two no but I think I
remember reading a line so long about
Jenna Dewan and Channing Tatum and like
because they faked it for so long I
actually thought that mine was wrong but
it wasn't which is that like he's an
outrageous cheater she is like so
insecure that she's like always how does
he has to go to everything with him
right and by the way wouldn't you be
insecure too if your husband was so hot
and like you really weren't famous you
were famous for me
want a them not like Duan right and
we're famous for being a good dancer
like which we know like doesn't really
get you anywhere in life right right the
resident and julianne hough like filled
the void for for what they need it like
you who were replaced right the only
mean one to answer and we have it her
never getting in with Dancing with the
Stars was a mistake
I feel like she thought she was above it
on some front like even as a judge by
the way those three judges who judge
Dancing with the Stars like what is
their background what makes that old man
qualified to judge other people dancing
I don't know I don't know about him but
now Julian's a judge okay yeah and she's
qualified I'm saying the three that they
version had the girl and then the two
got a old man and the funny guy like
with accent he's cute and he deftly
dances like I just get the vibe from him
I don't get that good Dancy vibes from
that old man no it's like he looks like
mr. Wonderful's like people who judge
gymnastics who like our because would
break the beam right ya know it's like
the irony isn't lost it's not I mean
tickets ticket this is really good for
Jessie J honestly for like we're talking
about her now when honestly I spoke
about Google just go youtube search
later today Jessie J Chinese talent show
she is so amazing and they like
subtitles and everything and she picks
like the best Whitney Houston song she
sings I have nothing like there is not a
note that Jessie J can't hit she is
really like one of the most talented
singers and in the music industry right
now and like nobody cares maybe they
will know maybe they will now so even if
it's a fake relationship for PR it's
working and I'm like here for it and
even if they just hooked up once and
they're not dating and he went to her
show maybe he's a big fan of the music
um cute right and it's like she wrote
that song flashlights for pitch perfect
2 which is an amazing song and they did
a pitch-perfect version and she has her
own version which is way better and they
literally like put every Z list
celebrity in pitch perfect and like she
wrote the song and they didn't even put
her in you know yeah I mean maybe she is
like I feel like she kind of is someone
like a Kacey Musgraves who started as a
songwriter never really intended to be
in the spotlight but like her talents
propelled her forward sort of they
propelled her like a couple inches you
know right but then I think maybe I'm
gonna give her the benefit of the doubt
which is like she was propelled
propelled forward she had got like she
was in the spotlight and then kind of
like retract a little bit like maybe it
wasn't for her that's what happened to
see you
and then she came back with a mask and
now she's giving her songs to Jennifer
Lopez and her voice I know she gives her
songs to everyone like it's so crazy she
has so many songs to get ed Sheeran
Beyonce Rihanna One Direction best I
love SIA like do you ever seen her
carpool karaoke yes oh my god she by the
way she's the same thing as Co she has
like um crooked bottom teeth and it like
is pretty and when she sings like she's
always like yeah yeah and in the carpool
karaoke like all you could see is her
teeth while because her yeah face is
covered but she has just like the most
amazing voice and it's like when she
sings like sometimes she cracks but it
sounds good
yeah yeah an amazing catalogue like we
saw her at panorama a few years ago I
know and it was the time of our lives I
haven't been to see a concert but I know
that when I go cuz I plan on it at some
point in my life like I will have a
great time you know yeah I'll be there
okay good
okay next story back to Taylor Swift
because I reason through today because
that's what happens with the celebrity
stories there's really nothing there's
really not much there there that's true
yes let's be out of here by 11:30
because I have to change oh you do
you're gonna sell my apartment oh we are
okay I mean otherwise we'll be there in
our early hey guys um
Taylor Swift stepped out so obviously
like there's days worth of news about it
Taylor Swift's 2018 a.m. a after-party
just gave us major FOMO says enews okay
so Taylor Swift had an after-party at
her LA home and her new crew now is
Shawn Mendes Hayley kiyoko Jack Antonoff
Kelly Kyoko yeah do you think that could
till he was there perhaps was at the AMA
so the rumors were true
so oh my god first of all I love that
Catelli and if she ever hears this
podcast ik I want her to know like if
you are dating Hayley kiyoko like I'm so
here for it and I support you and I just
like I want you to tell everyone I'm
happy for you and if you're happy but if
it's a lie like sorry for spreading
rumors that you write Ruby Rose of
course and then a bunch of backup
dancers so like this is her new squad if
you like Hayley kiyoko is like randomly
famous like how did she get here no it's
like it's our it's our fault it's like
we were sleeping you know cuz we're old
and [ __ ] and like she's been coming up
on what like on vine like what platform
I don't like where people listen to
music
no because we're old what's her song I
don't know Taylor yeah I don't know
because I'm just like there's a one word
that you keep saying it's like didn't
but yeah it took one word some more it's
like if we didn't know that camper who
was obsessed with Halsey that's how we
would have felt about Halsey that's a
joke conductivity and she would have
been a big star because it got old
yeah that's a good point well I don't
know Hayley kiyoko and I feel like her
famous like annoying because like she
got on Taylor strip stage and that was
like friends with the crew and like I've
been working so hard for years I'm like
and it's so hard for me not to say like
Hayley kiyoko Sweeting because of like
Kaylee Kyoko Sweeting Kelly cuoco and
she's not speeding anywheres no divorces
no but like it's a one-hole name no by
the way I don't feel that way at all oh
my god I want to say Hayley kiyoko
Sweeting every time I say Jesse J I just
don't say Jesse James Decker like that I
understand yeah where Jesse James right
which is what a good size all very um oh
she's from lemonade mouth Hayley kiyoko
that's not an that Disney yeah that
bridgit mendler is from lemonade mouth
and she's a star okay that would that
would be like saying oh my god pretty
Larsson she's from Sochi going on thirty
six chicks whatever well okay at least
you two start like that makes me feel
better like I didn't miss something I've
seen the poster for Lemonade Mouth on
Netflix and purposely ignored it no no
and I've been told that I would like it
but purpose ignore it
well I really want to know with Becca
till he was out this party like now this
is all I can think about it if she is
like I'm so jealous but like also happy
for her I guess
yeah wow that would be like it would be
a step up no I know I just you notice
thing about last night cuz heard Dean
and then Higgins were like the wants to
go to the Amy it's obviously because
like they have risen the ranks at I
heart and like I heard catapults certain
people like and I'm just so curious it's
like why them three you know what I mean
I'm like what happened to Ashley I write
well maybe she was like busy you know
otherwise she would have been the Ashley
I is never too busy for a red carpet
especially like a real one that's true I
don't know I don't know why Dean was
there because I don't think his podcast
is like anything else oh he does his
podcast now with Jared and Vanessa
Grimaldi so maybe Jared and Ashley I
like actually like got paid to be
somewhere or something and they cook
just couldn't make it
no like literally I think every I would
give up five thousand dollars they
couldn't make time in their busy pants
dropping schedule
oh I can't move you gotta mark your mark
to take time scheduled but I never
realize that but that's Marky Mark like
my mother so much better like I didn't
as a kid I didn't work well of course
and his pants shopping schedule what
does that even mean I don't know I my
schedule is I get to take his pants off
or his pants we're always hanging low
and by the way if we know anything now
it's like Marky Mark's schedule is pants
dropping he wakes up at 2:00 in the
morning yes he's been shopping schedule
has only gotten even more penstemon
no the pants are now fully like on the
floor there are no pants to begin with
he has no time for pens lol okay this
next story is a sleeper story why you
really like buzzing through I mean
that's what someone's the Liberty story
is like what what more do you want me to
say about Hayley kiyoko speeding I don't
know I'm just like not done with the
fact that I could tell he was probably a
teller says house I'm like I'm really
right I need you to internalize it but
what is there to say cuz like for me
it's like I feel like I'm pretty much
like almost on the same level as Becca
Tilly like she came from The Bachelor I
can move digital so people like don't
take us seriously but we barely like a
lot of people know who we are like I
don't know and like I very randomly get
invited to like cool [ __ ] like she very
rarely yeah I'm always like Becca Tilly
is gonna be there I'm not like pressing
bay right and like so now I'm thinking
like oh it could have been me why did I
have to be married right or maybe like
Ben could step up his game and what
become presidential Swift
yeah maybe release his country song
finally oh my god
Jackie last night Fenne was walking Theo
and he called me and he's like I wrote a
couple lines to a song today I forgot to
tell you and I'm like okay like
sometimes I just like say okay cuz like
it's not worth like being like what the
[ __ ] are you doing you know and I had to
just apologize for being an incredible
[ __ ] the night before they apologized
of course and he was like honestly thank
you and he's like I understand what
you're going through I said things but
you're going through so he's like I have
a song I know my great and for the most
part like when he like gets these ideas
I know he's gonna forget about it so
like me like getting involved it's just
like unnecessary and then he comes up
and he sings the song it's like and it
was like it wasn't terrible but like I
was like what are you doing he's like
I'm gonna record it like my friend will
like works in music and he can record it
for me and I'm like you cannot do that
like I didn't gonna say I'm like yo I
released a song it's America but I was
like literally stop just let him because
he's never gonna finish it and by the
way like if he does how funny would that
be like Zach heard a song for me and
they
it's so cute no but like I literally
said you have to copy everything I do he
said what do you mean I'm like I'm
writing a song you are yes I told you
this Nate didn't acetate about the
songwriter in the Hamptons no you didn't
yes I did well everything about you
didn't answer it what did you say
I said that I was staying in the
Hamptons and I met this guy who is a
songwriter and he wrote Kim Zolciak new
song and has written like a bunch of box
like that okay I don't I didn't see any
and I was thinking like maybe I should
write a song and like it would that be a
good move for my career cuz like I'd be
doing it as a joke but I also really
have a good voice but I don't people to
think am I trying to become a singer
which I'm not I'd write is you just hung
up your dream right and I still am but
like I just think it would be good to
have a my own song that like the
toasters could pop to and be my own song
that I own that like if I ever work I
can play it on my show like I don't have
any right like issues but it's an
amazing song right so I'd he's it would
be like an Erika Jayne song like a Bop
and like that has like a good message
like grab a spoon or something I don't
know
and how's it going well so I just signed
the paperwork cuz there's like a very
like with the fees and everything cause
like he wrote it are you paying a lot
for the song it's quite expensive yes
and I just I think it'll be worth it and
I'm not really doing it to make money or
anything like I'm doing it cuz I think
would be hilarious and maybe kind of
good but I don't know what message that
sends to the universe like I might do I
take my career seriously so I'm not sure
about it right but then as like manager
was against it and sometimes you release
a song gretchen Rossi and your joke
sometimes you release a song and you're
an icon can be tardy yeah countess I
agree and my manager was against it
which obviously made me want to do it
even more right and now I'm like not
100% sure what I want to do okay
well think about it and in the meantime
like let Ben write a song like thoughts
on it on myself I had like now this is
all for in new news for me and I get all
facets of what you're saying like it
would be hilarious and it would just be
like a fun thing for us but you know it
might also like we reflect poorly on
like where you see your career going
right and like right like I really I'm
just like serious too trying to be a
comedian and I think I'm doing a good
job like I take it sketch comedy very
seriously so like and I wouldn't [ __ ]
with that you know right and it's like
you can't do it all and even if you can
do it all like you have to do everything
at the highest level so like but this
isn't gonna be at the highest level it's
just gonna be one song even if it's a
great song like it would be like melissa
gorga right but she wasn't a comedian
right anyways next story is a sleeper
story but I find it to be quite
interesting
okay Bradley Cooper and Irina Shayk
barely speak during their dinner date
Bradley Cooper's of stars born may be a
hit at the box office but the actor and
director did not appear to be on cloud
nine with his baby mama Irina Shayk on
Tuesday are we still calling people baby
mamas like is that natural Tori I
believe that it is and just important to
know Irene the shake is not related to
shimmy and shake no it's so important to
know because it's the saddest thing I've
ever heard it was simple to use a list
models out there who looks similar with
the same last name and they're not
related it's it's like not like Cohan or
like Smith and it makes me like each of
them less cuz I thought they were
sisters coming up together yeah I love
just like a couple of gals I know but
instead I have spam on my one paychecks
of course I am
Chucky's iPad has virus on page six only
oh my god it now I lost the story all
right well while you get it back I guess
I'll perform okay you're giving me a
million reasons to let you go did you
add MJ of course I did I always wonder
like why okay who wrote the song its
back its back but I'm not done you get
spam again just steal the show cuz
you're given me a million reasons no I'm
gonna screenshot the story even me okay
no you can go the couple had a low-key
dinner date at masa in Time Warner
Center and spies told page six they were
serving some major attitude to each
other quote they were not happy a spy
told us the couple sat down he was in a
hoodie and she was fresh-faced no makeup
and they barely spoke to each other at
the start of a meal halfway through she
started looking off to the side and he
was Moody Cooper and model Shaikh have
been dating since 2015 the couple
welcomed their first child together
Leah last year that's definitely weird
no big lady weird vibes no remember when
they were fighting at rebel did
Wimbledon and those pictures are like
her crying and him yelling at her but
like they're always fighting right like
what are you guys fighting about you're
beautiful right and you know that like
this is not the life like he had wanted
no like you know that like he just
thought he was having sex with the model
and then she got pregnant and like he
wasn't planned and now he's like he's a
good guy like he's that he's loving the
right thing loves his mom so like he's
doing the right thing and like not
abandoning her but I don't think that
they're happy with each other and it's
like so sad because like but then I also
think about like okay if there was
people watching every meal I had with
Ben after a long day like okay sometimes
I don't talk sometimes were just both on
our phones and sometimes like two nights
ago like I'm a huge Trekkie [ __ ]
I don't know if that makes his
newsworthy you know yes and no I feel
like even when you're like not at your
best you don't not speak for an entire
meal yeah this is remember this isn't
the first time we've seen like
contention between them that's the point
and like they know that there a list
summaries they know when they go to a
restaurant people are looking at them
and so this was the best they could do
like if I went to a restaurant and even
if like I was feeling in a bad mood and
I knew that like as they were looking at
me and it was gonna be in page six like
I would put on an act
oh my god of course actress over here
totally backed up the day it's 11:11
Mukesh get your bad Gucci bag get you
mad did you give your maze crack era me
Scott oh okay wow that's out of control
they give me like very Pittsville vibes
and I think they like just moved into a
big house in Pittsville because neither
of them are happy with the situation and
like I think she thought by like getting
pregnant that she was gonna nail down
the guy that everyone wanted and she did
and like he's not the guy that she
thought he was going to be because he
didn't intend intend to have this sort
of life right and I think he's in love
with Lady gaga right I'm hoping he deaf
I think like working with Lady Gaga like
I don't know if he they're like soul
mates and he's in love with her but I
think it like gave him a taste of like
oh wow there could be more for me out
there yeah and like I could have dated a
singer right you can no not even a
singer like a megastar icon no but now I
don't think Lady Gaga's the girl for him
like they're both they're too big of
stars that's true but I think he could
have dated like Jessie J right like he
had a type of like like who could he
leave to him every night Paolo yes sing
to me Pablo
totally that's an excellent point you
raised and like I don't know I really
like when celebrities date people in the
industry who aren't celebrities so like
Lady Gaga's engaged to her agent from
CAA Christian Carina and like I like
that like I think it's probably good for
her career thank Reese Witherspoon right
it's nice to have someone who know
anything right someone who knows the
business but it's not trying to like to
be in the front of every picture so as
much as I don't want Lady Gaga to break
up with Christian Carina like she can do
so much better than that way me and I
really like I I expected more for her
and I think Taylor Kinney was like the
perfect guy for it cuz like yes he is a
celebrity
but like he is like a steady job making
those NBC checks he is not like the most
famous person but he is the hottest no
and also it's like she's a singer he's
an actor Bradley Cooper's an actor right
now he's actually a singer Jackson
Mane's moon and he should date a singer
they're not competing for the same jobs
watches are darling
I never
someone please pirate that movie
incentive tweener just to go to the
movie theater and set up a tripod for me
so at night live stream it I have a
flight coming up like they'll be so
great even though on my way home from
Alabama I watched three identical
strangers and they didn't finish it but
they have it on tell to us why intend
tomorrow to watch it and I was just
about to get to like the climax and it
is the most upsetting movie I don't know
if I can do another upsetting movie
because I just watch the room right no
but this is like so it's so real and
they have two or three out of three
other brothers and like it is the most
upsetting movie I've watched in a while
and it wasn't even like a pit it was
just like sadness and they had this
grandma and she was like making me cry
like but if I do watch it just don't
spoil it no it's gonna be I think it
should be a toast maybe of the week like
that is okay we need some positive
movies before we can get to the negative
because I'm still I still think about
room before I go to sleep every night a
couple Secretariat should lift your
spirits what a serious but on Monday we
will also there will be show tomorrow
you won't be here I don't know who my
coast is yet I haven't made moves maybe
been maybe I'm ready bill maybe I'm
ready for him again okay and they love
them he can test out his new song oh my
god so I know that people do love Ben
and like Who am I to not give the people
what they want no totally I can never
like guess or put like predict what the
people like yeah like when I think
you're gonna like someone you don't like
them as much as I thought you would and
when I think you're gonna be about
someone you love them right actually
that never happened that part never
happens where I think they're not gonna
like someone and they do know for the
most part I'm like oh they're perfect
and then like the toasters hate this
person and I'm like what yeah weird yeah
okay fifth and final story a little
business snapchat unveils new original
shows to lower back users okay snapchat
the saddest company on earth is hoping
it's new original content will bring
will help bring back former users and
appeal to existing ones I'm just gonna
tell you right now this is a bad plan do
not spend any money on it on Wednesday
the company unveiled its first
collection of snap originals including
scripted programs and gawky series
produced exclusively for the platform
the shows will include drama mystery
horror and comedy the company is
partnering with popular social media
stars such as summer McKean and Dylan
Jordan never writers from TV shows such
as Riverdale and Friday Night Lights for
the programs unless brighter Ross is
working on this I'm not interested the
shows are terrible and can be been trust
too
and I know that writer oz isn't working
on this because like between river
downstream in the TV it's like his plate
is full no this is not my plate this
this is like I had heard that they were
gonna do this like two years ago when I
went on CNBC to talk about snapchat
going public they were like asking me
what I thought of the future and I said
snapchat is like intending on making
like literally like long-form TV shows
and the fact that it took them this long
and they already lost all their users is
like sorry you slept on it for too long
and when I was checking the snapchat
Daily Mail snapchat every day like that
would have been the time for me to like
also maybe watch a show they're like
this is over and I was just having this
conversation with my managers because
like they were like what like let's say
because I was they will talk about like
a future and like the Tosun like what we
would want to do they're like let's say
the snapchat because they are spending a
lot of money on digital shows like let's
say snapchat came to you they wanted
exclusive they gave you a ton of money
and exclusively do it on snapchat I
literally would say no well how much
money right but like that's how and as
someone who like used to be the biggest
advocate of snapchat like they totally
lost me on every front I like have the
app and actually was thinking about
deleting it I'm going to soon also
controversial statement it's gonna go
against everything trend forecasters are
predicting and investing in but people
do not want to watch stuff on their
phone they watch them on their phone
when they have to yeah on the plane on
the train but if I'm sitting in my bed
and I have a TV up or I can watch some
snap original on my phone I'm gonna
watch TV right or a computer a computer
works a lot of people watch computer
where it's - like if you're a college
student or if you're at work but like if
I'm in my bed I don't own a TV but I
have my computer and I have my phone
like it's not gonna watch something on
my phone people watch things on their
phone out of necessity but they would
prefer to watch it on a big screen
so stop investing in mobile only content
either than the toast because people
can't watch on TV while they're at work
which is why we aren't here people watch
it on their computers computers and
phones or podcast no weird like it
depends if you have a split screen it
depends on your job if you can get if
you sit in the corner and you can get
away with watching on your computer you
do if your boss looks at your monitor
you probably watch on your phone propped
up against your desk with your morning
toast pop saket helping you write
interesting okay so this is in me an
epic fail and it's gonna be very sad
make sure you sell all your snapchat
stocks
totally when I was on CNBC which is
my best interview today I warned people
do not do not buy Ben's dad really
wanted to buy because like then he
thought he was like supporting been
doing it and then took me mad more like
don't do it and I was right you did say
that yeah well it would have been fine
too by then and then sell quickly but
this is just very sad but it's no one's
fault other than their own of course say
they weren't on top of the world
Facebook wanted to buy them four billion
even Instagram copying their stories
future didn't sink them like like when
Instagram introduced videos they synced
immediately vine was dead in a day when
stories came out people were still loyal
to snapchat right especially and then
people started doing both and then
literally people migrated completely
because Instagram was other than pretty
filters Instagram gave you more of
everything work with swipe tags text you
see different text in different spots
you could put whatever the [ __ ] you want
it on your story whereas on snapchat you
had to choose between three color
filters and it was just like they they
wanted you to play by their rules where
Instagram is we make the rules if we say
we want something enough it'll show up
right that was the best part about
Instagram it's like the users had like
an ear to mark like if ever almost
meeting like oh I wish they would stop
Auto playing like Instagram remember
when at snapchat automatically made you
watch the next person's story when you
click someone and it was like so
embarrassing and everyone complained
about it it took them over a year to get
rid of that why because they were all
too busy like boozing it up in Silicon
Valley and listen to our qualms totally
and like I got verified on snapchat and
it was like the greatest thing ever
because so few people were and like now
it means nothing nothing you've got to
get the toast verified on Instagram yeah
even though it's not stopping us it
wasn't strong we hit and we're already
out like 80 point to the Instagram is
like my life and I just like watch it
every day just like watch the number
grow and we have to do something like
major when we get to watch Oh what's so
crazy about this is that first of all
the chose Instagram has only been up for
six months and we are at more followers
than we ever were in doing over a year
at the breath yes so that's why I'm just
like obsessed and what should we do let
me get two hundred I will have to think
about it I take a bath in honey mustard
oh my god no I'm so waiting on it me too
um well think about maybe wood
special episode no it's something bigger
I'm not like too big no yeah like we
don't to throw a party no no like we'll
do that when we get to a million yeah
let me get to ten thousand patreon users
that's first well be saloons and we need
like a cute photo shoot with empty
Vasquez of course also I just use like a
photo shoot I was thinking the other day
like they have chat that I used for all
my shows like people show up and they're
like who is this because that's not me I
did it in your old apartment I remember
literally 40 years ago I just got
engaged so I got engaged in 2016 it's
time it's time I can use to it head
touch my hair is short and my head shots
but I think that's better for the head
shot five look I really feel like one
day like maybe when we're off like we
should come back in here get rid of the
chairs and stuff use the pink backdrop
and the leaves and just like take cute
photos okay
I'm available okay but not today
Kardashians you finally watch a lot of
Japan I watched because I had heard so
much about it and I don't feel like
pressure anymore to like keep up every
week with the Kardashians but I'd heard
so much about this people like Kim's
being crazy and I might oh [ __ ] and I
knew his converse Kourtney and I kind of
Pitt because I'm so team Kim and
everyone was like I'm team Kim but I
thought Kim was being crazy so I watched
the episode and I kept like waiting for
this like me to drop but like Kim being
crazy and I just couldn't disagree with
everyone less for two reasons basically
if you don't watch episode Kim went to
Japan to do this easy photo shoot and
what I didn't know that that's what she
did it's so cool like that explained it
to me and it was ingenious she shows up
like at airports or random places in
these outfits obviously she gets mauled
by paparazzi's for 10 seconds they take
over a million photos and they're out in
the world community leaders right and
that's the collection and I did that for
all of the looks and that's the lookbook
they don't hire a photographer in the
studio and hair and makeup like that's
just her life so she planned this trip
to Japan because she wanted Japan to be
the backdrop like the whole point of
this trip was work it was to shoot what
was it like 17 looks I don't know how
many he was so much it was so many and
by the way she looked so cute except I
don't like fully understand or love the
easiest etic it's not made for me but I
appreciate like someone's art and I
don't understand fashion so like it's
not for me yeah I appreciate the easiest
etic I think some collections are better
than others this one had its moment
right when she wore the puffy vest and
the spandex shirt I thought she looked
so cute and like the glasses dude she
looks futuristic but when she was
wearing leggings a long sleeve and
best like that's not totally that's just
a jogger bragging outfit the woman in
home alone did it better but at the end
of the day like that's art I guess so is
I don't have to like it or agree with it
but it's art no yeah yeah but I just
feel like it's it's working slow energy
it just is like that's mere did that's
like high fashion so then Kourtney and
Khloe wanted to tag along because they
had never been to Tokyo which i think is
so weird like they've been all around
the world they've ever been to Tokyo I
mean I haven't been all around the world
but I've never been so kyo and if you
were going I would be there in like they
been to Australia which is the furthest
place from America and you haven't been
to Tokyo he's gonna stay in Tokyo
maybe he'll just came in Kim had this
whole thing planned with the glam and
every outfit was planned and Kourtney
Khloe came along cuz they'd never been
and they'd really want to go and like
have a sister strip which is so cute but
like the point of the trip was work and
the first night Kim goes in one of the
outfits and she's ready to be paparazzi
then she's walking with Kourtney and
khloé and they looked terrible like and
Kim was being mean I didn't think
Kourtney looked that bad that eyeshadow
it was terrible but the her outfit was
really cute but she they're wearing the
k'kaw eyeshadow that blue is Kim's blue
and she was promoting and you saw the
palette on the desk and that was around
the scene I saw the palette that that
color came out so like why are you
knocking the eyeshadow it's your
eyeshadow totally totally Chloe looked
insane yeah the eyeshadow was terrible
to dress the earrings everything was
terrible she's like pregnant like give
her a break right and butter I didn't
realize that they like had this thing
with Chloe's hair cuz what's wrong with
her hair I don't know at the end they
were like it's every time we make fun of
Chloe's hair as if like they always say
it Kourtney and Khloe and Kim and I had
never heard it but she does do wild
things with her hair and I just thought
that was like an interesting tidbit it
is but what is wrong with her hair most
of the time like no it's just like the
the styles that she chooses like she
does the hi baby don't know like was
brings a lot she's either short or long
wavy I don't know I guess it's like a
family but I don't get it like me need
unless he just looks good on TV and it
doesn't look at him realize maybe maybe
it looks like PC and like you could see
the tracks like the difference between
the extensions and that's bad that's
horrible
so when they get back to the hotel
Kourtney Kim is like saw the paparazzi
picture she's like I'm trying to get my
pictures and like you guys look like
clowns
and she definitely being like a little
harsh calling them clowns was me and at
dinner she was harsh but it was
it was fair they did look weird calling
them clowns was mean but she's working
there they're trying to make it funny
and they're picking it up and then she
like was persistently like just being
more mean than like insulting the Glan
people but when Courtney was wearing
that red thing with her shoulders like I
didn't know what the [ __ ] she was doing
and when Kim was in the room like
literally being like your wife's hell
she was like yelling and I was like why
are you doing this and then I would
realize like basically Kim is styling a
photo shoot and if Courtney wants to
come on the trip and be in every photo
like you have to be in tune with the
aesthetic because like you only get one
chance to shoot the thing and then I was
like okay then being offended like they
have every right to be but but Kim like
was sort of justified I understood where
she was coming from but like she was
being like very mean about it she said
like a couple things that were
unnecessarily mean as opposed to being
like this is a work trip I'm gonna need
you to adhere to this vibe and if that's
the case by the way you need to tell
them before the trip and they need to
pack like you should pack for them
totally should style all their literally
and like the glam team and the stylist
should know that this is our vibe
legally I didn't think that Kourtney
looked that terrible any of the time she
looks like fine yeah Kim was like you're
not like uh what was the word she is she
was like oh she said Kendall E no no yes
she was like you she dressed like Hamlet
which is just like very sad yeah um you
know she's like you're not being like
you're nothing hearings like
revolutionary or anything but why does
it have to be it doesn't have to be but
something to say just like Kim was
self-aware enough that on two points she
said I know I'm being harsh and she
apologized once and then was mean again
and then the end of the episode they
were like you should just compliment
someone before you're so mean and she's
like okay like she's like I don't know
with Courtney's like she always thinks
she's right and she's it's end-all
be-all but she is a wall and that's it
and Kim was like she can be someone can
say that her Kim you're being me and
she's like I know I'm sorry like she
apologized like I don't know there's
something to be said I feel like
everyone was like people who are team
Kourtney was like waiting for Kim to
[ __ ] up and like jumped on her and Kim
is like yeah I like Kim was aware like
reasonable enough to be like yes I was I
took it too far and I'm sorry yes I just
I think Kim's message was fine like this
is a work trip it was just if I didn't
get in the delivery was alright like she
was just like saying things that like if
a sister ever said to me like look what
did she say like first of all you look
like clowns like me yeah and like
laughing
and then when she was in the room and it
was like grainy footage almost where she
was like yelling at the glam squad and
like just saying that court nothing that
Courtney where is this like
revolutionary and like she's being like
cheesy with her Asian Japan vibes like
that's just like me you can all you may
say is like we're here to work like you
need to get into like a more easy vibe
even if it's just all black like plain
just don't like it's a bit much like
right but she was just like digging in
and it's like that's just not how you
talk to your sisters no I'm definitely
Kim apologist in the way that I look at
it it's just like Kim was totally
justified in in wanting them to change
their looks her delivery was way too
mean but also if your sister like you
don't feel the need to filter like you
can just say it cuz like it's yes but
things like that shouldn't count of your
mouth about your sister she should have
been more direct less less direct but
also she did the right thing in the end
and apologized and like didn't start
fights with people like crossing her
like that's what Courtney does like if
you say something like she can't be like
you're right she has to defend her
actions like to the death where Kim is
like yeah I was mean I'm sorry I guess
but I also like what Courtney said later
on which was like kind of funny and it
was just like it was sad for kamo and
she was like it takes more courage for
me to say that I'm hurt than to just be
a [ __ ] back to you and be like you're
wearing turquoise shoes and a puppy best
and like yes which is also funny and
sort of true it is but Courtney says
that like as if Kim is saying these
things because like Kim's insecure and
doesn't want to talk about her feelings
like no Kim out of all them it's like
the most direct and doesn't like hide
behind her feelings like Courtney was
saying that as if she took like a moral
high ground like I'm in tune with my
emotions and I can say that I'm hurt and
I'm not just gonna be a [ __ ] whereas
like you are being a [ __ ] because
you're not saying something like there
wasn't anything Kim Kim wasn't hiding
anything by like being a [ __ ] you know
anything that's what Courtney does yeah
but she could have done that and then
they just would have both been [ __ ]
right yeah yeah yeah but right they
could have done that but Kim isn't like
insecure or like hiding or not saying
something and it's just covering it up
by being a [ __ ] which is what Courtney
does so Courtney was like I'm not doing
that like as if Kim was but she's not do
you don't say no but Courtney could have
this all she was saying she could be a
[ __ ] - yes but Kim wasn't being a [ __ ]
because she was like this anger and
that's much of them contacts like when
Scott and Kris went to lunch and they
were like I can't have Kim look at me
cause like then she just like tells me
everything that's wrong with me it's
like who would want to be around like
it's like when you tell me like
or anyone that I have a pimple it's like
I know what I look like
yeah chefs I pack a bag buy a ticket go
to hell totally uh and why didn't Kanye
just go on the trip like it I felt so
much pressure for him to get everything
right like honey she was anything that
was a look oh you look fired like oh my
god when he was like that was in luck
I'm like no way I was like fine it's me
they have picture the picture everything
wrong no totally that was so bizarre and
freaky and he's like oh wait no you
would fire oh my god kill me
um but they were cute and like she
worked so hard for her husband she works
she's so cute but you know she also
loves it like they're a match made in
heaven
hopefully the rumors aren't true that
they're getting divorce because like he
creates all this stuff like she lives
she just walk out of the car get her
picture taken go get mcdonalds and like
make it a look yeah and they're just
like doing the thing that they love
totally I feel like he should have been
there like totally along the way to help
her because that was like a big
undertaking and like why did they have
to go to Japan like that is so so far
Vegas has survived I feel like he made
Kim like the way that she is now like
critical of the way everyone's everyone
looks because like do you remember when
they first started dating and she was
living in that house they seen at her
closet and he was like that's bad that's
bad and he is like so critical just
because like he has his artistic eye and
like he's very obsessed with like looks
and fashion and she was like what like
this is from Louis Vuitton no this stuff
that like Chloe where's now is what can
be used to wear actually looks down on
it but it's like you were no better than
that when literally all you guys wore
with jeans and heels and lasers I mean
really shared dresses and like long hair
like you guys were cheesy as hell
stilettos so don't like don't knock
where he came from
totally and Kanye I definitely made her
into like this fashion I can't fashion
critic Jess cuz he that's what he did he
literally came into Rosen pointed out
all the things she had right and now she
does it to everyone else yeah and her
house is empty
yeah whatever it works for them yeah Oh
riverdale also okay I don't even
remember what happened cuz like so much
Rd trial there's a injury I'm so glad
that like he turned himself in I'm so
glad that Veronica didn't get to go into
that hotel room at the five seasons and
I talked to the jury cuz like that is
not how the world works now and when
they did that I'm like wow the show has
lost to like lost a grip on reality that
is like a major major crime no huge and
like I said you could just waltz into
where a jury is I guess like in River
there's only one hotel like where there
would be security I just like obviously
our she's not gonna stay in jail forever
like they have to figure out a way but
like I loved when it was Archie Veronica
hire I'm like against the world
I know and Archie was like taking a high
room side against you was like the worst
decision I ever made and like in general
I feel I guess you need to take your
family side but here it's like var Chi
is my everything like I love them so
much
Hyrum Lodge is so evil and lie so evil
it's like Archie did so much for you you
couldn't let one thing slide like you're
taking over his town like just let this
slide I really want like Veronica could
be doing more because at the end of the
day the only thing higher logic kind of
cares about is Veronica not even had
anymore not anymore
but like the worst thing she did him to
say I'm not your daughter anymore like
you should pack up and leave and like
not talk to him and like then maybe it
might get through to him like she's just
like she's not doing enough look she
could end this all and it's like I can't
believe she's still living under his
house while he's framing her boyfriend
for murder and she's still dating her
boyfriend right like stay at Betty's
write about Eddie Alice is being so
crazy with Paulie for sure and until the
end which is unclear what actually
happened with the babies in the fire
because Betty like clearly was like
tweaking yeah um Alice was making some
good points
so and I was like you know maybe the
farm sounds kind of good I know she was
just really seemed like a calm person
who's like with their chakra but like
because she was way too intense before
right but if you're a person who is very
intense and like is going through a lot
and you're like the anti chakra vibe to
hear that kind of talk is like leave me
alone so Betty was justified to being
like mom you're crazy but she was being
like a little mean because that that
isn't the day Alice was like in a good
place after her husband turned out to be
a murderer right they're there they're
dealing with it through it and Betty's
not know and it's like you through your
whole summer into this law case and you
felt and like what did you even come up
with that helped the case anything molly
ringwald being her son's lawyer was a
terrible call
yeah they thought they should have had
it mayor motors gonna defend her son
even if he's a murderer that's the
premise this she mother had mayor McCoy
be like the first seat like that like
the the main lawyer the one who talks
and delivers the talking points and then
Molly Ringwald on the other chair just
like being supportive but also being a
lawyer right that was like a bad call
and I'm glad they addressed it like she
was like maybe I made the wrong decision
being lawyers she said yeah I agree good
for you good for you for knowing that
too late now but the scene and they were
all like being cute at the pond beat
water the swamp swamp that was cute and
I mean I need more like that I know when
they're driving down the highway to
Youngblood by five seconds on my car
amazing song choice like they always do
good song it's like obviously Thunder
that was that would be like an epic
moment for me no it was so maybe like
puts her hands in the air right but me
my like she's like abusing drugs and we
got a bench
we got a lot of kissing scenes from
Betty and Jughead and I realized that um
Lily Reinhardt is not a good kisser
no she's kissing like she's acting
kissing but it's like that's your real
man like give him a smooch it must be
like so nice just like smooch that
you're mad but it also must be nice to
smooch KJ yeah this is gonna say kami
Mendes definitely likes kissing cachapa
cuz like who wouldn't but like when
Reggie and KJ are throwing the football
like I think I personally think AJ's
hotter cuz like I love him but Charles
yeah that he's hotter totally so like
she really is living the dream kami and
we got totally making out with both of
them legally like her daytime job
nine-to-five he's making out with the
hottest man alive who we've met so many
like sweaty ABS scenes from like I was
right and then from 5:00 to 9:00 she's
making out with Charles Melton also I we
got so many like bikini scenes like
randomly which I just loves because I
feel like I'm gonna just obsessed with
these peoples we're like follow on
Instagram and she's like I've obsessive
anime and now I got to like basically
see the Nick and there was some a
tellurian
only reason my Zack watches the show is
so pal I know it's not there because
everyone else was super tan in this
episode like they made it a point like
that was the vibe and then she's super
pale and it's just like it's uneven
playing field being pale like really
makes you look worse completely unless
you're her she looks amazing pale but
it's like it's summers it shoots out of
place
retinol so a pale person really
flourishes in like a very cute one piece
but like an open back right
where's when they had her walking into
the diner like some low-class stripper
it's like she deserves better with a
bikini cheryl has been through so much I
don't put her in those shorts I couldn't
agree more and cami wore on the highways
to be I didn't see which was a cute look
we're leaving baby sister their
underwear and bras it looks like
underwear
rise but you knew you were going on the
lake so I was worried for some reason
only looked at kami Mendez the boys were
definitely wearing boxers kami was
wearing a bathing suit no I think they
both away they wearing bras which would
make me think they're wearing underwear
why would cami Mendes wear underwear up
to her nipples because it's the look
it's Riverdale they're in the 1950s but
also in 2018 they don't have AC in the
courthouse that's by the way do you know
that literally for the first few
episodes of season one when everyone was
watching that I had to watch I was under
the assumption that it took place in the
fifties wait cuz you go to the hospital
and the doctors are in like sailor hat
right and then someone looked at a cell
phone and I was like that's what I was
like wait this show is now it was very
confused it's weird it's where they do
think I think they like to keep the
timing and Meg was it's not like super
technology heavy yeah um but they have
cars
it's an electricity yeah but all their
houses look like like bedrooms from the
50s like Betty's wallpaper right and
they don't have AC at the courthouse and
they're having another Manuel fans like
being spun but I like that I like it
that it's not like it could happen at
any time
well what I was gonna say is cami wore a
one-piece I mean high-waisted bikini
thank you
and I feel like you really don't get to
see on the show like how tiny she is cuz
when I met her I was like so shocked by
how frau petite short did model that she
was small from every angle like she was
you she turns aside then like and you
don't get that cuz they like never show
her full I realize like they always show
her waist up he's like a line dress is
like as if she's hiding something right
he's got nothing to hide the only people
who wear a line dresses are like curvy
people who don't want to show off their
curve of curves in the moment so you
think that like she didn't like pleated
skirts and you think that she is like
not so small and but she is yeah and
lilius mom they've just got like banging
bods and they're also like healthy bods
and they're disposed to aspire to their
positive body images for sure and Lily's
eyes were looking like so white and blue
last night like I I thought they put a
filter on her eyes they might have to
make her like look more strung out or
she's used those top drug drops that
everyone in Hollywood uses I need them
yeah they'd make your whites whiter and
you're like greens greener or a terrible
3 dude yeah or take a filter yet the
whole show is like trying to filter yes
last night's filter was different than
usual because usually it's like like a
darker hue
more moody the last night it's summer
it's Labor Day so like we're gonna give
them like more of a Kelvin filter and
they're not in school yet no I totally
felt Betty when she was like I can't go
back to school you know that's like how
I used to feel it's like the world's
ending she's like I threw my whole like
life into this internship like basically
I had no summer she'd be easier than an
internship at a law firm yeah but she
was just like they never even have
homework she was like I just when she
chose not to have a break totally but
like also was her best friend and she's
sort of in love with Archie still and
she but she didn't do anything actually
helpful so she could have stayed home
you know what she didn't want to be home
it's like the show was set up in the
beginning took for you to really think
that like Betty and um aren't she we're
like meant to be boy-next-door girl
next-door neighbor's love love love and
now I don't feel that way anymore right
and I think it's also because Lily and
Cole are dating in real life and the fan
hood ships them so much that it affected
the story it that I definitely affected
the storyline totally and I mean because
no one else but us ships have archie so
much that i hope they stay together
forever forever like she when he tried
to break up with her she was like no do
i love them so much and i just get so
worried that they're gonna break up it's
like if they didn't break up through all
of this and he like chose her over her
own father over his own father like him
then maybe they'll be together forever
maybe maybe will be like in a hard time
watching because my DVR was all [ __ ]
up and we started we watch the middle
then the beam in 12 to 24 then we were
like wow we really watch 24 minutes
somebody always we can see the first for
12 minutes then we went 1 to 12 i said
150 we're like who does Archie murder
yeah I thought he murdered the guy who
got out of jail when the gun went off
but no he was being set up for that lake
house murder that like hot dog thing
with the stew knees and the Ghoulies I
don't understand and it's like so stupid
I mean like I could give a rip about
jagneaux saying the words and addy
Simmons I don't give a rip what you do
and like um next week I'm Dallas house
eyes they're like ginger goes to her
about Leanne's problems and she goes I
don't give a dog's rip like I always
think like you know how we say rot in
hell like Britney or they I always think
I don't give a rip do you know I always
she went like - now that she says it
again what does it mean now I think it
means a [ __ ] [ __ ] has a dog [ __ ] yeah no
I'm doing
for what you do well you can rock now
that's the best thing ever
also Betty having a seizure at the end
was some of the greatest acting I've
ever seen pretty clearly Reinhardt is
like an amazing actor Green because last
season was very much her season and she
was going through so many emotions and
she was an incredible incredible actress
like she don't groove in herself
you don't like think of Riverdale like
the teeny bopper show with like everyone
having 12 million Instagram followers is
also the show where there's like amazing
acting happen happening but Lily
Reinhardt is an amazing actress and that
seizure was professional yeah that
wasn't that wasn't anywhere DC here it
was okay well Jack and I have to go cuz
we've a meeting and I'm so tired and I'm
like starting to have period cramps so
like I really need to go okay I have my
doll at home thank you guys so much for
tuning in to the morning toast the
millennium morning show we're back
tomorrow I'm in Atlanta I'm playing the
buyers theatre so make sure to go
tickets that girl with no job calm
Heather McMahon will be there and maybe
Brielle Baron um tomorrow we're doing
Ben you're doing that um tomorrow I'm
gonna reach out to ban if you can't do
it I'll find someone um it'll be a
premium show don't worry so make sure
you're here tomorrow to met Jackie
holding down the fort with a fun guest
host on the morning toast the millennium
morning show we go live Monday through
Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on
YouTube and maybe Facebook to make sure
you're subscribed and you like us all
over the place and then we're also
available as a podcast anywhere podcast
can be listened to
so either subscribe to some Spotify if
you're an Android user or listen to us
on the iTunes podcast store thank you
all so much for listening I'm Claudia
osh right girl with no job feel free to
follow me
I'm Jackie I'll show you Jackie O
problems please follow me or I will cry
bye
you